das urteil ist einstimmig und folgenden
schluss anders behring breivik geboren
13 februar wird verurteilt wegen treten
des strafgesetzbuches § 45a seien 121 aw
in verbindung mit § 148 1 erste straff
alternative und 233 erste und zweite
abteilung und 233 erstes zweiten
abteilung mit 940 und dem pendant von
der 47 12 330 142 zusammengehalten von §
62 des strafgesetzbuches zur
sicherheitsverwahrung nach § 93 c nummer
eins mit einem zeitraum von 21 jahren
und eine mindestzeit von zehn jahren
nach § 93
die haftzeit und auch die
mindesthaftzeit gehen 4 45 tage ergab
für die untersuchungshaft dürfen sich
setzen
familienhintergrund des angeklagten und
seine schule und jugend wurde 70 geboren
seine eltern verheiratet eine tochter
der vater hatte drei kinder aus erster
ehe die familie nach seiner
halbschwester zogen sie dann noch auf
sie zu die mutter versuchte das
sozialamt um unterstützung bei der
erziehung und das wurde auch gewährt im
dezember 82m so der angeklagte
kindergarten park bis er zur schule ging
die mutter des angeklagten nahm kontakt
auf zur familienratgeber stelle
es gab einen besuch in der kinder und
jugendlichen der kinderschutz abteilung
dieser situation der vater des
angeklagten gerichtsverfahren
angestrengt hatte kontakt vater werden
wurde die jugendbehörde wieder in form
so eingeschätzt in abstimmung gestellt
84 angeklagter hat aufgegeben
politische motive für diese tat zu haben
seine meinung ist festgehalten in seinem
kompendium erklärungen und gesprächen
ist es auch festgehalten wurde
er hat angefangen mit einer zusammenhang
übersicht über sein blickwinkel
urbevölkerung als opfer einer zunehmend
ausländer
die heutigen urbevölkerung nie vorgelegt
wurden
die norwegische zugelassen
kulturkonservative in den medien
es gibt keine neuigkeiten
christliche lebenseinstellungen mit
friedlichen mitteln zu verbreiten
wenn man die arbeiter verteilt dazu
zwingen kann
die einwanderungspolitik zu ändern
könnte dazu beitragen zu ändern bezieht
sich auf den im sogenannten
kulturmarxismus der durch das kollegium
der schule noch weiter verbreitet der
kirche die ausgestellte als der papst
noch militärischer leiter weg und es
geht darum die christianisierung europas
zu stoppen sein volk zu retten jahres
selbst gegeben
die handlungen auslösen
präventive eingriffe zur rettung des
netzes menschenrechte lassen ist zu
die eigene kultur zu verteidigen
probleme mit seinem islamfeindlichkeit
mit seinen rechtsradikalen und packten
mittels zusammenhänge seien
ausländerfeindlichkeit
die islamische system nämlich große
verbreitung gefunden hat
es geht um die anschläge den usa um den
karikaturenstreit es ist ein geheimnis
zu mobilisieren
er behauptet dass durch geplante
migration nach europa europa islamisiert
werden so das gericht bemüht sich damit
dass die zeugen sich dazu äußern viele
betroffene die nicht körperlich versehrt
wurden psychische störungen gehabt
leiden unter angst schlaflosigkeit
konzentrationsproblemen nach dem
terrorangriff der neurologischen klinik
für klinische psychologie gegeben um
mögliche psychische leiden aufgrund des
terroranschlages im regierungsviertel
teuer darzulegen akuten
belastungsstörungen posttraumatische
stress leiden depressionen und
verschiedene angststörungen die
psychischen störungen und leiden die man
erwarten kann
das kann zu erhöhten störungen des
psychischen wohlbefinden beitragen
es geht auch um betroffene die
angehörige verloren haben
die auch dadurch psychisch traumatisiert
worden sind